[Musique]
habemus papam nous avons un pape les
catholiques vont désormais célébrée
chaque jour françois à l'église saint
victor de guyancourt les fidèles étaient
déjà ému avant la messe ce jeudi midi
je viens pour le placer les smad y
épauler l'élection des papes
françois polypes je suis très heureuse
pour les missions du nouveau parc parce
que ça donne une joie à l'église d'avoir
un parent d'un autre continent mais qui
est pour tout le monde
quelque chose de nouveau vous êtes
content oui madame un moment fort a
partagé avec le jeune père fabrice du et
qui vit son premier changement de
souverain pontife
c'est une nouvelle figure pour laquelle
on va prier au quotidien qui va pouvoir
aussi donner certaines directions à
l'église et chaque pape bâ
arrivé avec ses idées avec des projets
pour l'église donc ça va changer un
certain nombre de choses même s'il faut
pas s'attendre à une révolution majeure
dans les quelques semaines ce nouveau
pape le pape françois et ben imprimera
l'histoire de l'église à sa manière un
pape jésuite jesús tout ce sont des
prêtres religieux qui ont fait le voeu
de pauvreté et qui vivent de manière
assez exigeante cette pauvreté
françois ça fait référence à saint
françois d'assise saint françois
d'assise et le ce1 par excellence qui
incarne la vertu de la pauvreté qui
incarne aussi l'amour de la nature
l'amour le dialogue interreligieux
françois saint françois avait été
discuté avec les musulmans à l'époque
pour que ce dialogue était plus que
complexe
donc ça dit déjà fortement quelque chose
de la manière dont il sera pas en chaque
messe le pape est nommé nomme le pape et
l'évêque par leur prénom alors tout
l'enjeu c'est de pas se tromper pas
mettre notre pape benoît à ce moment là
par jesus luz
je sais
sa première fois s'est bien passée et
restera un souvenir extraordinaire tout
comme la découverte du pape
hier soir au moment où j'ai appris que
la fumée était blanc je recevais un
couple en préparation au mariage c'était
dans mon bureau au presbytère donc je
leur ai dit ce que je crois qu'ils ont
un peu halluciné mais je leur ai dit est
ce qu'on peut tout arrêter parce qu'il
faut qu'on voie le nouveau papicha et
chercher une bouteille de champagne et
donc avec ce couple on a débouché la
bouteille de champagne est accueilli le
nouveau pape et une fois seulement qu'on
savait qu'ils s'étaient j'ai fermé mon
ordinateur et on a pu continuer la
préparation au mariage
[Musique]
c'est tout ce qu'il reste du restaurant
est longue pour toi les templiers ils
étaient environ 2 heures du matin dans
la nuit de vendredi à samedi quand un
incendie s'est déclaré et a ravagé
l'ensemble de l'établissement
les pompiers avertis par de nombreux
appels se sont rapidement rendus sur les
lieux et ont dû mettre en oeuvre
d'importants moyens 50 hommes des
casernes de maurepas montini plaisir les
clés bois d'arcy et rambouillet ainsi
qu'une douzaine de véhicules ont dû être
mobilisés pour faire face à l'ampleur du
sinistre
dans un premier temps nous avons pris
les précautions donc d'évacuation des
personnes qui étaient autour du sinistre
et puis après nous avons fait attaque
massive sur le foyer principal est sur
le côté pour éviter la propagation du
sinistre est au bout de deux heures le
feu était complètement circonscrit et
étangs et après nous avons dû éteindre
les petits foyers qu'était limitrophes
pour éviter qu'une reprise de feu ce qui
nous a pris six à sept heures au total
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
précise l'origine probablement
accidentelle du sinistre
un court circuit serait intervenu dans
la salle principale peu après la
fermeture du restaurant lincendie
provoqué s'est alors propagé à
l'ensemble de la structure aux boiseries
très nombreuses
le restaurant les templiers employés 20
personnes nous allons d'abord essayer de
mettre à notre personnel à l'abri il ya
bien entendu un certain nombre de
dispositions à prendre très vite dès ce
dès maintenant les experts commencent
déjà à venir et puis ensuite bien
entendu pour ce qui nous concerne chef
d'entreprise notre objectif numéro 1
maintenant c'est de repartir très vite
dans des délais très brefs
dans cette structure ou dans une autre à
l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur de la
commanderie
l'accès au site est évidemment dangereux
et interdit une surveillance policière a
d'ailleurs été mise en place
[Musique]